from the moment that you told your wife
you wanted to be a filmmaker
what immediate changes did you make in
your life in terms of craft
or trying to understand it was um
reading and studying everything i could
about
about um writing about um
you know how how it's structured or how
people
how you format and just the basics of
things so
i kind of took it as my own way of
going making my own school you know of
like
i want to learn this this is this is
interesting you know i just can't
you know write on a um napkin or or
legal pad i just wanted to see that you
know i guess i could but
i i didn't so the changes i made was was
really
making a commitment um to trying to get
better at it it wasn't
a thing that i said this is going to be
a career
it was a thing that was like i just
wanted to do it you know
um so i didn't know if it was even going
to be
something feasible that that didn't even
cross my mind i just
it gave me something that i could wake
up and do and challenge myself
and and that i think i just never
reached a point where
um i was frustrated enough to quit i
think that was
that was what um the screen ran because
obviously once you have a script then
you needed to
you know you know produce the thing
so you have to shoot the thing and then
i think
i just got um i just tried to do it off
because it seemed fun you know call call
my friends up or
my family and go hey could you just you
know come could we just spend this
weekend and then
we and and do this and um and then
that's how it all began
you know just to see if i could do it um
from start to finish
so and then when i did a short film um
it was fun
it was i liked the whole process the
storyboarding the
getting people together mapping things
out and and seeing the words come alive
um
from from actors or or family members i
don't know
i would call them actors but but um
they were gracious enough to help me out
so you said previously you went to a
bookstore that was in texas sorry was it
in dallas or where it was yeah dallas
it was half it's called half price books
um which
which um people would sell back their
books and
had you know you could get all these
books for really really
um you know cheap and and things like
that so i i would buy a whole bunch of
uh
um like books of all directors
books on i think i got that robert
rodriguez book there the um the rebel
um book and then i got a couple other
tons of other things and then um then i
was searched for scripts
scripts online to read you know thank
goodness for the internet you i mean
it's like
you could just get anything you want and
you know and and
and that's what i you know um
that's what helped me you know you know
um
just trying to get learn and learn and
learn and get better
were there other writers in the dallas
area or was that something that was not
part of the culture at that time there's
um
you know i've always had uh i always
wish i
was able to be more uh gregarious or
open
get involved more of the the community
or specifically the film community or
theater
um uh i i just didn't wasn't able
to do that uh at that point because i
think um
i didn't know where i was headed myself
so i just started
just to write i think it was such an
isolating and freeing thing
um but i i really didn't meet too many
other
um filmmakers at the time because i
didn't think
i was one i was just trying to write
right you know and um
and and figure it all out i sort of did
the same thing
with my photography um career
and uh you know there's many ways where
you you could go you could
become an assistant you can do this i
just called myself wrote a business plan
and called myself a photographer and
shot
as many things as i can weddings and and
and things i could and and figure out
lighting and
and and and all that kind of stuff and
then
i think i work better that way um
it might not be the right way but it at
least i could kind of like
know you know understand understand what
i'm doing wrong but i
i you know oftentimes i wish i did have
a mentor or a group and go
hey what's you know my second act sucks
why am i why am i always drowning in
this and
they could say you don't have this
there's not a defined goal there's this
you know
blah blah blah blah um but i was really
honest
because if you read a script like
ordinary people if you read a script
like leaving las vegas
and then you read your script you got to
be sort of honest and go
that's not close yet you know you got to
work on that why
why how come i can't why am i turning
each page like these other scripts that
i love
and that was the same thing when i was a
photographer when i looked at photos in
the magazines
i had to go i to be a photographer
or working photographer the hard truth
is my photos
have to look as good or better than this
so until i was able to do that and gain
the confidence
i was just hard on myself in that way so
um i just gotta get better
whether it took two days or two years or
fifteen or ten i was
um ready to put in put in that because
um
i don't know why you just kind of like
keep going because you wanted to get
better i think um
so i took the same approach with with
filmmaking and screenwriting
um i i wanted to write scenes that that
made me turn the page
myself yeah do you think it's okay to
just not be part of a group you know
there's a lot of pressure especially in
western culture
to be part of a group and join something
and do all that
and that's great some people really rise
to the occasion i think some people are
better just by themselves internally
yeah that's a great i think it's up to
your personality and i think
you need to find that balance it's like
sort of like dieting i guess
it's like you can't do one extreme
especially with filmmaking
writing itself is so alone but the
filmmaking process is so collaborative
so you
need to work with other others and be be
able
to do that so so that's what i wanted to
do i wasn't
wanted to strictly be a writer i wanted
to work with other people but i love the
isolation
of the writing process but now i've
learned
the the beauty of rewriting and
and and the input of other people and
and
and and getting notes and and getting
hey
this is you know you got to you got to
get
into the to it faster you know you got
to do this oh this is
maybe not so so um
you know so right for the for the story
so i like i like taking notes um because
it get
it gets me to think of other things
because when you're writing for a script
it could take you three six months four
months whatever
you're so alone and that maybe that's
why other people have writing partners
um you know so you could bounce ideas
but to get notes it gives me an
idea oh i never thought about that let
me
plug that in and maybe i could come up
with something else it's
pretty freeing for me to to do that and
um
uh not take it personal you know and
and and maybe i'm just more optimistic
that go like
people are telling you this not because
they don't want
you to make a crappy story it's because
they think it could help and it's your
job
to synthesize all that information and
see if
it does i think that's that's what
happens that's even being a director
because you get like so much
information and so many uh decisions you
have to make
um and you have to make it within split
seconds sometimes
hey is this makeup too heavy hey what's
the color of that clothes or
is this location work on uh are we going
to do another take
does this the actor um feel safe you
know things it just
you know happens so much so
um you really have to be on your toes
and and um be adaptable i think
i think that that's a vital skill even
for screenwriters is to be adaptable
and um to take to take notes well
and feedback criticism feedback
criticism
um and go just get back to work and and
take it and you know what you could do
it
you make a version of the notes you
could do it and if you don't like it
you go back to the previous version and
continue that way
but at least you shouldn't have a
if you follow that process right for at
least for me
i wouldn't have a um writer's block
you know because someone gave you a a
door go to this door it might might not
be the right door
but you get to go through it so you
could write that out you know
it doesn't fit i didn't feel right or
maybe
you know maybe i'm missing that scene we
need to add that scene in again
so um it's it's interesting process
it's it's definitely sculpting you know
it's you could
continuously keep writing
it's it's weird something maybe it's
it's funny just to drop the pin and stop
writing it because i can
i could i'll re-read this re-read the
script constantly or
the first page the first line and go
i gotta stop and i'm a little obsessive
now i take a break and you know
um even the rhythms i would read it out
loud the feel of the words
flow right you know
so that's that's what i because i would
imagine if i was a reader
if i was reading this and if it's boring
or
or that exposition's too long or the
state or the scene heading is too long
you know i need to cut that out you know
so that's
that's sort of my process lately is
cutting cutting cutting
i think that's being an editor because i
edit as well so you get used to
cutting you know cutting pieces together
looking back on it now do you think you
made the right choice for yourself
choosing the filmmaking path knowing
that you wanted to challenge yourself it
sounds like you
you don't compete with others you kind
of are very much about challenging
yourself
maybe i'm wrong you know if i if
i you know think about it and um
you know i i'm very lucky to be able to
make that choice
and and feel like it is the right choice
um
uh certainly it's it's not the easiest
of paths um to take
you know it's it's it's not like if you
go
um get your bachelor's and you get your
master's or phd
and then you you do your residency and
you do this
you're and you pass a license that
you're going to be
a psychologist you know there isn't like
routes and and
there isn't a structure that even
determines that you are
um so there's well there was blind faith
i think it just more of like um
uh you do something and then you get
obsessed about it and you do everything
you can
to make it happen i think that's just
what happened
what happened to me um and filmmaking
ended up being a medium i was drawn to
because i
i kind of failed at everything else i i
was i wanted to be a musician and that
didn't work out i wanted to be a writer
that i didn't
that didn't work out and i and i i was
got into photography and i got this and
i was like wow you could
combine that on that's what filmmaking
was called i never even knew that was
possible you know
um so once i knew that the possibilities
of it
it maybe i felt like a kid again i was
like
so i think that's what drove me in
in in telling a story um visually
with music with sound um uh
that that was i was
hook line and sinker you know and and
and coming up
coming up with stories each time and
developing that
and then now you know working with
actors working with art department
working with the crew
uh you're like whoa this is awesome you
know
you you asked me before um
about being um you know isolated but
now you get to get out of your
hibernation and then play you know play
with everyone
um i think that's the fun part about
filmmaking
and i think you said just off camera you
knew what you didn't want
you know and so yeah that's a
yeah exactly exactly i i was very good
at
good at that i was i maybe not didn't
know what i want
but i knew what i didn't want and that's
the same thing with like
if i compose something in a frame i know
i didn't want that in the frame
i don't want that in a frame so so what
is it that
that's left in the frame um
so i took this a sim similar approach
um uh you know i didn't want this to
happen i didn't want to
have regrets i didn't want to um
you know uh because i did i had those
before i wasted time i wasted this i
didn't have confidence
i didn't have these things and um and so
when i started like you asked um i just
started one day at a time to
see if i enjoyed it and then um if i
didn't
i probably would have been obsessed with
uh
making ramen noodles that'll be next
thing how do you make those news how do
i get it right
right texture oh is this broth right
okay then you want to sell
it then you want to do it so i probably
would have been obsessed with something
else
if i didn't you know fall like
in love with filmmaking
you